Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter One, Episode 6, Part Two.
Next, crisis and recovery.
After about fifteen years of economic growth and progress, Denmark was in 2008 hit by the international financial crisis.
The crisis started in the USA, but spread quickly to Europe, where it became deeper and longer than in the USA.
That also applied in Denmark, where the gross domestic product, that is, the value of the country's total production, shrank by a total of over five percent in 2008 to 09.
That is the biggest setback for the Danish economy since the Second World War.
The crisis also brought some years of higher unemployment.
When the crisis set in, unemployment was the lowest in thirty years, and there was a large surplus on the state budget.
It was turned into a deficit, but Denmark was still not hit by as big problems with state deficits and debt as most other EU countries.
At the same time, Denmark's foreign debt has turned into a large claim, so that other countries owe Denmark more money than the other way around, and the surplus on the trade balance has set repeated records in the last twenty years.
In 2025, the surplus was about three hundred eighty-two billion kroner.
Since the middle of the 2010s, there has again been higher economic growth, a surplus on public finances and lower unemployment in Denmark.
In 2024, the Danish state's revenue was thus one hundred thirty-three billion kroner higher than expenditure.
And unemployment was three point one percent in April 2026, compared with six point zero percent in April 2013.
Now, the challenge for the welfare state.
Anders Fogh Rasmussen was in 2009 elected the new Secretary General of the defence alliance NATO.
He was succeeded as prime minister by his party colleague Lars Løkke Rasmussen of Venstre, who was prime minister from 2009 to 2011, and again from 2015 to 2019.
Two years later, in 2011, the Social Democrats regained power, and Helle Thorning-Schmidt became Denmark's first female prime minister, for the next four years until 2015, when Lars Løkke Rasmussen again became prime minister.
The challenge of moving more people from transfer income and into the labour market has been the motive for numerous Danish welfare reforms over the last thirty to thirty-five years.
Both Lars Løkke Rasmussen's and Helle Thorning-Schmidt's governments headed many such reforms.
One of the biggest long-term challenges for the welfare state in European countries is that there will be fewer people to pay for the welfare that more people are to enjoy.
This is first and foremost because people on average live longer.
As in other Western countries, life expectancy rises by a couple of months every year.
That development is expected to continue.
At the same time, the birth rate has fallen, while expectations of the quality of elderly care and the health service are rising.
That means there will be markedly more elderly people in relation to the number of fifteen to sixty-four-year-olds, and fewer to work and pay for welfare.
At the same time, working life starts later because of more education.
All in all, there is a lack of labour in many places on the Danish labour market, even though there are still people out of work.
Many different reforms have therefore aimed at increasing the labour supply, to get more people to work, earn money and pay tax.
In this connection, the period in which one can receive support as unemployed from an unemployment insurance fund, the A-kasse, has gradually been shortened since the 1990s and since the last reform in the area in 2010 has been two years.
The so-called Retirement Reform from 2011 was meant to ensure a faster and bigger rise in how old people typically were when they withdraw from the labour market.
Further, reforms were agreed in 2012 and 2013 respectively that should ensure that fewer people go on early retirement pension, and that fewer are on cash benefit.
A number of tax reforms have also had the declared goal of increasing the labour supply by lowering tax on labour income.
Students have, through a series of reforms, been encouraged to start their studies earlier and finish them faster.
Then came the pandemic.
A significant challenge in the years 2020 to 22 was a global pandemic with Covid-19, which was caused by the so-called coronavirus.
The virus was discovered in China in 2019.
In Denmark the first case was registered in February 2020.
The government, the Folketing, the Danish Health Authority and others tried to contain the disease through a series of recommendations and restrictions.
They were to ensure that people, for example, did not meet too many other people, that they kept distance from each other and that they washed their hands in sanitiser.
A main purpose of the restrictions was to prevent too many people being infected at once, so that the hospitals were not overloaded by many admissions.
Therefore, you had to wear face masks on buses, trains and in shops, among other things.
You also could not travel as freely between Denmark and abroad as normal.
Schools were also closed in periods, and pupils were taught at home via the internet.
In addition, many restaurants, cafés, museums and theatres were closed in periods, and football matches and other sports took place without spectators, just as many worked from home.
The health service tested thousands of people daily to find the infected, who then had to stay home for some time so they did not infect more.
The coronavirus has mutated several times into ever more contagious variants, and the disease has so far hit the country in three big waves.
An important means of fighting the disease in the long term was to vaccinate the population.
It took only about one year from the outbreak of the disease to develop vaccines against coronavirus, and in December 2020 the first Dane was vaccinated.
Since then, most, about ninety percent of Denmark's population, have been vaccinated with two or three jabs.
Globally, almost seven million people were registered dead with coronavirus, including almost ten thousand in Denmark.
And finally, the political map today.
In recent years, more new parties have come into Danish politics.
Five of these, Liberal Alliance, the Alternative, the Denmark Democrats, the Moderates and the Citizens' Party, were elected to the current Folketing.
Liberal Alliance was elected to the Folketing for the first time in 2011.
The party arose with a policy of more tax cuts, bigger economic incentive to work, lower public spending and more private market economy.
The Alternative, Alternativet, has, among other things, emphasised that greater focus should be put on the green area.
The party believes that more should be done for the climate, nature and the environment.
The Alternative was elected to the Folketing for the first time in 2015.
In addition, two parties, the Denmark Democrats and the Moderates, emerged shortly before the general election in 2022.
Both were formed by politicians who had earlier been leading members of Venstre, and both were first elected to the Folketing in 2022.
The Denmark Democrats was founded by former Minister for Immigration and Integration Inger Støjberg.
The party is critical of immigration to Denmark.
Furthermore, the Denmark Democrats emphasise better opportunities for the population in the more thinly populated areas of the country, which are found, among other places, in large parts of Jutland.
The Moderates were founded by former prime minister and party leader Lars Løkke Rasmussen.
The party sees itself as a party in the middle of Danish politics and wants the political cooperation to take place "across the middle", with participation of both the Social Democrats and the centre-right parties.
In 2024, the Citizens' Party, Borgernes Parti, emerged.
The name refers to the party's view that power must go back to the citizens, because the state, through, among other things, too many laws and rules, too high taxes and too much digital surveillance, has got too much control over citizens' lives.
After the general election in 2019, the Social Democrat Mette Frederiksen became prime minister in a minority government consisting only of the Social Democrats, with the Social Liberal Party, SF and the Red-Green Alliance as so-called support parties.
And with a new general election in 2022, a majority government was formed with Mette Frederiksen as prime minister, consisting of the Social Democrats, Venstre and the Moderates.
In March 2026, yet another general election was held.
At the election, the trend continued that the old parties collectively get fewer votes than they did before.
Thus the Folketing's five oldest parties, the Social Democrats, SF, Venstre, the Conservatives and the Social Liberal Party, together got fifty-seven percent of the votes.
That is clearly less than eighty-one percent in 2001, seventy-five percent in 2011 and seventy-two percent in 2019.
Almost half of the voters, forty-three percent, thus voted for the seven youngest parties: Liberal Alliance, the Danish People's Party, the Moderates, the Red-Green Alliance, the Denmark Democrats, the Alternative or the Citizens' Party.
After the election, yet another government has been formed with Mette Frederiksen as prime minister.
It consists of the Social Democrats, SF, the Moderates and the Social Liberal Party.
The twelve parties elected to the Folketing in 2026, by share of the vote, are: the Social Democrats, with the letter A, SF with F, Venstre with V, Liberal Alliance with I, the Danish People's Party with O, the Moderates with M, the Conservative People's Party with C, the Red-Green Alliance with Ø, the Social Liberal Party with B, the Denmark Democrats with Æ, the Alternative with Å, and the Citizens' Party with H.
In addition come the four members of the Folketing elected in Greenland and the Faroe Islands.
The chart in the textbook gives the numbers.
In seats: Social Democrats thirty-eight, SF twenty, Venstre eighteen, Liberal Alliance sixteen, Danish People's Party sixteen, Moderates fourteen, Conservatives thirteen, Red-Green Alliance eleven, Social Liberal Party ten, Denmark Democrats ten, Alternative five, and the Citizens' Party four.
In percent of the vote: Social Democrats twenty-one point nine, SF eleven point six, Venstre ten point one, Liberal Alliance nine point four, Danish People's Party nine point one, Moderates seven point seven, Conservatives seven point six, Red-Green Alliance six point three, Social Liberal Party five point eight, Denmark Democrats five point eight, Alternative two point six, and Citizens' Party two point one.
A cheat sheet for the questions about which party is oldest or newest.
The oldest are Venstre and Højre, both organised around 1870.
Højre was renamed the Conservative People's Party in 1915 to 16, so the Conservatives count as an old party.
The Social Democrats became an independent party in 1878.
The Social Liberal Party came in 1905, SF in 1959, the Red-Green Alliance in 1989, the Danish People's Party was first elected in 1998, Liberal Alliance in 2011, the Alternative in 2015, the Moderates and the Denmark Democrats in 2022, and the Citizens' Party in 2024.
That completes the history chapter.
Here is your final recap for Episode Six.
The Berlin Wall fell in November 1989, and the Soviet Union dissolved in 1991.
The Maastricht Treaty was rejected with fifty point seven percent in June 1992, and the Edinburgh Agreement was approved with fifty-six point seven percent in 1993.
The four opt-outs were Union citizenship, the euro, defence, and justice and immigration, and two still apply: the euro and justice and immigration.
The Danish People's Party entered in 1998.
Anders Fogh Rasmussen was prime minister 2001 to 2009.
The twenty-four-year rule applies to spouses.
Afghanistan in 2002, Iraq in 2003, the Muhammad drawings in 2005, and the Copenhagen terror attack in 2015.
The financial crisis hit in 2008.
Helle Thorning-Schmidt was the first female prime minister, 2011 to 2015.
Covid-19 reached Denmark in February 2020.
Poul Nyrup Rasmussen of the Social Democrats was prime minister from 1993 to 2001.
Anders Fogh Rasmussen became NATO Secretary General in 2009.
The Red-Green Alliance was first elected in 1994.
The 2015 attack also targeted the synagogue.
Helle Thorning-Schmidt is a Social Democrat.
Mette Frederiksen has been prime minister since 2019, and the latest election was in March 2026.
Congratulations, you have finished Chapter One.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which former Danish prime minister became Secretary General of NATO in 2009?
Option A: Poul Nyrup Rasmussen.
Option B: Anders Fogh Rasmussen.
Option C: Helle Thorning-Schmidt.
[DA] Hvilken tidligere dansk statsminister blev i 2009 generalsekretær for NATO?  A: Poul Nyrup Rasmussen  |  B: Anders Fogh Rasmussen  |  C: Helle Thorning-Schmidt
The answer is B: Anders Fogh Rasmussen.
It appeared in the November 2021 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Anders Fogh Rasmussen
Question 2.
Who was Denmark's first female prime minister?
Option A: Margrethe Vestager.
Option B: Helle Thorning-Schmidt.
Option C: Mette Frederiksen.
[DA] Hvem var Danmarks første kvindelige statsminister?  A: Margrethe Vestager  |  B: Helle Thorning-Schmidt  |  C: Mette Frederiksen
The answer is B: Helle Thorning-Schmidt.
It appeared in the November 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Helle Thorning-Schmidt
Question 3.
Which party did Helle Thorning-Schmidt belong to when she was prime minister from 2011 to 2015?
Option A: The Social Democrats.
Option B: The Social Liberal Party.
Option C: Venstre.
[DA] Hvilket parti tilhørte Helle Thorning-Schmidt, da hun var statsminister i perioden 2011-15?  A: Socialdemokraterne  |  B: Radikale Venstre  |  C: Venstre
The answer is A: The Social Democrats.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Socialdemokraterne
Question 4.
Which party did Lars Løkke Rasmussen belong to when he was prime minister in 2009 to 11 and 2015 to 19?
Option A: Venstre.
Option B: The Social Democrats.
Option C: The Conservative People's Party.
[DA] Hvilket parti tilhørte Lars Løkke Rasmussen, da han var statsminister i perioderne 2009-11 og 2015-19?  A: Venstre  |  B: Socialdemokratiet  |  C: Det Konservative Folkeparti
The answer is A: Venstre.
It appeared in the May 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Venstre
Question 5.
How has the unemployment benefit period for the unemployed developed since 1994?
Option A: It has become longer.
Option B: It is unchanged.
Option C: It has become shorter.
[DA] Hvordan har dagpengeperioden for arbejdsløse udviklet sig siden 1994?  A: Den er blevet længere  |  B: Den er uændret  |  C: Den er blevet kortere
The answer is C: It has become shorter.
It appeared in the November 2022 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Den er blevet kortere
Question 6.
Which party was founded in 2022 by the former minister Inger Støjberg?
Option A: Nye Borgerlige, the New Right.
Option B: The Moderates.
Option C: The Denmark Democrats.
[DA] Hvilket parti blev i 2022 stiftet af tidligere minister Inger Støjberg?  A: Nye Borgerlige  |  B: Moderaterne  |  C: Danmarksdemokraterne
The answer is C: The Denmark Democrats.
It appeared in the November 2022 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Danmarksdemokraterne
Question 7.
Which party has Inger Støjberg previously been a member of?
Option A: The Social Democrats.
Option B: Venstre.
Option C: The Conservative People's Party.
[DA] Hvilket parti har Inger Støjberg tidligere været medlem af?  A: Socialdemokratiet  |  B: Venstre  |  C: Det Konservative Folkeparti
The answer is B: Venstre.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Venstre
Question 8.
When were the Moderates first elected to the Folketing?
Option A: 2007.
Option B: 2015.
Option C: 2022.
[DA] Hvornår blev Moderaterne valgt til Folketinget første gang?  A: 2007  |  B: 2015  |  C: 2022
The answer is C: 2022.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: 2022
Question 9.
Which of the following parties is the oldest?
Option A: The Social Liberal Party.
Option B: SF.
Option C: The Red-Green Alliance.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende partier er ældst?  A: Radikale Venstre  |  B: SF  |  C: Enhedslisten
The answer is A: The Social Liberal Party.
It appeared in the May 2023 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Radikale Venstre
Question 10.
Which of the following parties is the oldest?
Option A: The Conservative People's Party.
Option B: The Socialist People's Party, SF.
Option C: The Danish People's Party.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende politiske partier er ældst?  A: Det Konservative Folkeparti  |  B: Socialistisk Folkeparti  |  C: Dansk Folkeparti
The answer is A: The Conservative People's Party.
It appeared in the June 2020 and November 2020 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Det Konservative Folkeparti
Question 11.
Which of the following parties is the newest?
Option A: Alternativet, the Alternative.
Option B: The Socialist People's Party.
Option C: The Red-Green Alliance.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende partier er nyest?  A: Alternativet  |  B: Socialistisk Folkeparti  |  C: Enhedslisten
The answer is A: Alternativet, the Alternative.
It appeared in the November 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Alternativet
That's the end of this part.
Well done.